[Music]
what is the birth of a superhero the
Superman pulling his shirt open the
first time and revealing the ass do I
knew that Wonder Woman needed an
incredible moment Diana wants to be a
hero from day one but what it is to be a
hero does not become clear to her until
no man I think the biggest reason I was
obsessed with it was really from a
character place from Diana's point of
view and her saying that's what I'm
gonna do and stepping up over the edge
that was such a powerful way for her to
step into being our Wonder Woman
I kept focusing in on the fact that this
isn't about who she's fighting and it
doesn't matter who's on the other side
of the trench this is about war this is
her stepping across no-man's land and
saying no to mankind's method of war so
for her to track the bullet coming
towards her and then smash it away like
no that won't be happening no we're not
going to do that and I'm stronger than
those bullets and then she takes on even
larger mortar fire as she continues down
the no-man's land I thought that's who
she's fighting she's fighting gun
violence oh that was the opponent there
were definitely arguments about are we
really gonna put Diana and a Wonder
Woman costume out in the freezing cold
in the winter but we had to do it you
have to build no man's land it had to be
real or might not have looked right it's
funny because we talk about actors and
though they really have an easy job just
know they don't gal gadot could not be
more applauded when she's halfway naked
doing this beautiful dramatic moment out
there when the rest of us are in massive
down parkas so it was brutal I think the
huge amount of pressure but it was just
a wonderful embrace for the world to
support it and come to it the way that
they did it was pretty incredible
there's this one and fan interaction
that really sticks out in my mind I was
at a screening and a man was there in a
wheelchair and he told me that so many
times in the hospital he'd had to have
help and he would have no clothing on
and he would have to stand up and be
held out of his wheelchair in these
metal crutches
and it took all the bravery that he had
in the world and when he saw Diana step
over the edge in no-man's land in just
her Wonder Woman outfit willing to brave
the world just like that it was him it
felt like him the fact that huh decision
to stand up and move forward because
she's an unlikely hero and as a
vulnerable person and it made him cry
and he got emotional and she was telling
me that was one of the most touching
sand interactions I had I'm theory just
thinking about it it was such a powerful
moment